avant qu'aurélien de bissy nous
rejoignent pour la chronique culture
justement comme chaque semaine les
sorties ciné les nouveaux films à
l'affiché le diwan est allé à votre
rencontre à la sortie des salles
recueillir vos réactions il trouvait que
l'hydro y est bien
c'est sensationnel c'est s'éprenant
c'est
c'est un enseignement formidable pour
l'avenir d'après eux les films d'un jeu
les films et c'est très émouvant
je me suis un petit peu ennuyé au départ
mais franchement l'air la fin était très
sentimentale très touchante ça perd un
peu du charme par rapport au dessin
animé les années 80 toute la magie que
ça pouvait avoir beaucoup d'effets
spéciaux beaucoup de
deux scènes d'action mais une suite
logique du 1er mai - a moins bien fait
c'est du gros blockbusters en 3d ça ça
dépasse les mirettes c'est sympa et puis
tu vois là c'est pas mal voilà un film
d'action où on joue bas sur les noms des
grosses stars manche à nîmes tatum
dwayne johnson et bruce willis je
pensais que ça serait bien non donc
grosse déception mais cite une comédie
loufoque si drôle c'est pas du grand
almodovar mais bon voilà c'est vraiment
un super film et je pense que la 3d ça
apporte sa part vraiment quelque chose
parce qu'on a vraiment des beaux
paysages et donc avec la 3d ça mais
romancé paysage jean valère aurélia
bonsoir la chronique culture avec vous
comme chaque mercredi vous accompagne
sur ce plateau luc beaugrand bonsoir
directeur du ciné 7 à elancourt ahmed
matin ils vont soir un responsable
jeunesse à la verrière la verrière qui
pour la troisième année mène une action
culturelle pédagogique les jeunes vont
se familiariser avec l'univers du cinéma
et de la vidéo mais déjà aurélia le ciné
enfin une date d'ouverture voilà donc
nous recevons du boucan dites-nous
est-ce qu'on peut enfin annoncer la
bonne nouvelle
sous réserve de la commission de
sécurité bien sûr qui passe mercredi
prochain 3 avril à 9 heures tout devrait
bien se passer on va dire d'entre eux
devraient être ouverts au public enfin
après presque deux ans d'attentes à 15
heures voilà on peut enfin annoncé
officiellement l'ouverture comme vous
l'évoquez des travaux qui du coup ont
généré beaucoup de retard dans cette
ouverture de nous dire rapidement les
raisons de ces retards
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire on
pourrait en faire un film presque tu as
tellement je crois qu'on a cumulé on a
cumulé des tellement de choses
de la viande on a trouvé de l'eau dans
une des salles il a fallu poser un
risque grave fasse un peu technique avec
des pompes de relevage voilà si les
prêts l'humain des entreprises
défaillantes pas tout un chien le dire
et cetera un vraiment de pilotage aussi
du chantier qu'un pilote qui est parti à
moment donné
donc on avait plus de pilote et niort
fils qui a fait du hors piste plus de 15
ans et l'agglo cas ce qui concerne le
pilotage au départ mais les évaluations
c'était cinq mois et alors on nous avait
vendu effectivement les choses comme ça
dans un premier temps on fera des
travaux sur les deux salles existantes à
laitages et on en avait pour cinq mois
on rouvre les deux salles et on fait le
bas il s'est avéré qu'on a compris
allez on va dire deux mois après le
début des travaux ce serait impossible
est finalement l'ouverture normalement
si voilà rien on vous accompagne tout
footballeur on touche du bois tout le
monde sam karmann est ce que maintenant
les travaux sont comme eux comme
voulez-vous y est ce qu il appelle
est-ce que vous avez l'outil dont vous
rêviez absent alors ses quatorze mois
c'est fini c'est exactement ce exact
alors c'est ce que sam c'est ce que je
suis en train de me dire là on est dans
la dernière liste noire 6 5 il faut donc
on est ici ça ouvre un complice et pas 5
ont d'ailleurs eux vivent des
frustrations mais bon alors on a voulu
en nous ce qu'on a voulu c'est faire un
cinéma à taille humaine dans lequel le
mot convivialité est un sens ça en avait
avant ça on aura encore plus demain
parce qu'on a enfin un hall d'accueil
digne de ce nom donc on va pouvoir faire
des soirées la rencontrer
voilà donc on a une salle de plus on
avait deux salons à 3 on a un hall
d'accueil un vrai hall d'accueil ni de
ce point qu'un petit bar ouvrira les
soirs en cours de soirée quand ça vient
nous présenter son quatrième long
métrage avec plaisir voilà on a tout est
neuf du sol au plafond on avoue la clim
il ya la clim on est volé numérique
c'est numérique c'est en 4k les trois
salles donc vous ferez partie des
spectateurs ça va faire mal dans mes
conquêtes et binoy alors moi je alors
moi c'est alors c'est ma question
d'après est-ce que ça va être une
programmation et j'en suis sûr
l'udc est obligé d'avoir une
programmation aussi grand public et de
nommer il ya le sujet c'est qu'est la
qui est juste à côté est arrivé il a
c'est toute l'astuce de ces dames à 17
mars et de faire cette programmation qui
attire je pense qu'une partie mais aussi
de faire de l'art essaie de faire via un
label alors on est classée art et c'est
depuis très longtemps et c'est tout neuf
on a le label je ne faisant donc et
j'aimerais bien qu'on ait le label
répertoire ses terres et ses recherches
et découvertes etc
on va en tout cas on va tout faire pour
la voir donc cette troisième salle
justement on l'a voulu
pour la dédier à l'arrêt c'est d'une
certaine manière c'est à dire que hier
on était à peu près à 65 30 65 grand
public 35 arrêts c'est demain on sera à
50/50 super voilà c'est l'objectif est
donc l'objectif cmj s'est aussi souvent
de ça voilà c'est d'aller sur du cinéma
d'auteur c'est d'aller sur de la
découverte de jeunes talents c'est
d'aller sur la défense aussi deux films
qui sortent tu le sais très bien et qui
reste une semaine à l'écran et qui
disparaissent et qui sont parfois des
petits bijoux
voilà ce qu'il faut savoir au moins
trois films français qui sortent chaque
lame sur 18 ou 20 exactement
il ya la sortie a qui sortent sur 400
copies les autres il sort sur 250 et les
petits qui sort sur 100 au moins sur ce
show là ils ont une semaine dans les
multiplexes après viré
donc c'est le rôle de vos salles de les
défendre ce sera la possibilité de le
faire dès le 3 avril aux molière pour
vous je vais faire sur moi je trouve sur
les salles enfin bon l'horizon qui
s'obscurcit manettes on veut pas jouer
les oiseaux de mauvaise augure mais il
ya peut-être une inquiet de fédrigo a
signé voilà cinéma de proximité alors
cinéma indépendant vous êtes fervent un
militant ce sujet mais alors s'ouvre
prochainement peut-être puisqu'il ya un
projet d'ouverture d'un multiplexe à
maurepas vécu salle mais 700 fauteuils
comment vous vous accueilli ce projet
très mal je peux pas dire autre chose ça
chauffe commission le var voilà ça passe
on irait il a grandi et vendredi matin
donc alors si vous voulez que je sois
clair son sujet je suis pas un anti
multiplex il ya des multiplexes il ya
des multiplexes très bien en andains 150
ans donc voilà il est là il existe il
fonctionne très bien c'est sale voilà ça
m'en parler toute heure il ya un projet
de multiplexe à plaisir et la ville de
plaisir on sent mais on leur a posé la
question tient à faire son multiplexe
pons a été reculée reporter présent le
tour de table financier etc
mais la vie de plaisirs veut son multi
baisse qui a été autorisé d'ailleurs en
cdac et en scène assez bon maintenant
c'est la ville de maurepas son
multiplexe nous on dit simplement
humblement tranquillement attention sur
équipant attention sur équipement on a
déjà un multiplexe existants un futur à
plaisir et l'encours maurepas ce sont
deux communes sam le sait très bien ce
qu'ils habitent ils habitent dans l'une
des deux qui sont qui sont finalement
une seule et même entité
les gens de maurepas vont aussi des
miles en cours comme les gens de
l'enfant cide amour de sarah culty nema
attention je crois que ça va être paris
ouest le bain bon donc seymour pas mais
en fait c'est coignières l'âme à
coignières les gens ils y travaillent et
vivent pas peu je moi je
il me semble qu'il n'ya pas il n'ya pas
le public encore je trouve plaisir
oui c'est loin qui a cinéma plaisir je
trouve ces mois là je trouve ça très
bizarre d'autant plus que tout ce qu'ils
ont fait autour de ceux de ce truc leur
ombre
c'est juste le désir ça ne marche pas
quoi chaque fois que c'est aussi pour ça
qu'ils évoquent cette possibilité de
mettre un cinéma mais ça serait
forcément aux dépens du ciné 7 alors on
l'espère on vous portera pas
juste un truc le si ça se fait ce
multiplex un ciné movida
c'est à moins de 3 kilomètres du ciné 7
plaisir c'est 9 km donc c'est pas la
même chose comme ça me le disait très
justement en tout cas pour l'instant
c'est la réouverture du site et tout va
bien ce sera une date officielle le 3
avril logo quand vous restez sur ce
plateau sam karmann on vous remercie
d'être vous rappelle votre actualité en
3 avril vous remonter sur scène avec
marianne le bonheur au théâtre marigny
tous les soirs à 21h deux fois le samedi
et une fois le dimanche après midi à
15h30
voilà qui est dit merci encore à vous on
vous laisse partir vous êtes déjà très
en retard désolé aurélien on parlait
toujours cinéma avec l'opération de la
verrière dans un instant pour l'instant
une pose photo exactement donc nous
sommes allés rencontrer vincent de
louvigny qui expose en fait ces photos
de son voyage de ses différents voyages
donc toute cette aventure on peut suivre
à l'exposition qui a lieu au
conservatoire des arts de montigny on
regarde les images
et
des couleurs d expression presque des
senteurs il se dégage une atmosphère des
photos de vincent de louvigny l'homme
voyage depuis l'âge de 22 ans son
premier périple il a accompli en
indonésie c'est là que les blinois s'est
découvert une passion au coup de foudre
cf depuis j'ai l'impression d'avoir un
objectif dans les yeux comme je voyage
je voyage je vois plus les paysages je
les vois surtout à travers l'objectif
d'un appareil photo c'est comme si mes
yeux était devenue un objectif
vincent de louvigny m les bonnes lumière
et surtout le petit détail qui fera que
la photo sera différente
comme cette vue de bus plein en irlande
presque un tableau
quand j'arrive à faire un bon refait
jules inverse et ça donne une toute
autre vision de la faute au steak à
l'envers je la trouve moins belle alors
qu'à l'interpellent et le but d'une
exposition c'est de se dire mais je ne
retrouve pas j'ai juste eu lieu
certaines personnes sont allées cet
endroit ils m'ont dirigé par découvert
tout de suite vous l'avez retoucher ses
photos gras du tout en fait moi je
retouche très peu mes photos plus d'une
centaine de photographies est exposée en
ce moment au conservatoire des arts de
montigny vincent de louvigny a réalisé
une quarantaine de voyages cet été il
part pour bornéo un retour aux sources
et des paysages qui ressemble à d'autres
paysages connais pas un peu blasé non
parce que les gens sont différents parce
que les les personnes avec qui vous
voyagez vous fait autrement fait
d'autres rencontres - le voyage c'est
pas juste des des paysages c'est les
visages peuvent se ressembler
les personnes qui vivent dans ces pays
là elles se ressemblent jamais